if i had to know everything about
connecting people before I got started I
never would have built Facebook it's
easy to have ideas it's very hard to
turn an idea into a successful product
it's so difficult for us to hide people
15 years ago people who are not that bad
I said people can walk still walk on
sorry we hide them because nobody
believed Internet nobody believed
Internet what sublimation it's open mind
one word is believe and I believe in you
I want to see that amazing thing you
have inside you be unleashed onto the
world so you can have a big impact for
yourself your friend if your community
and for the world and so to help you on
your journey today we're gonna learn how
billionaires think success advice from
the top vol 6 rule number one is my
personal favorite and I'd love to know
which one you guys like the best and as
always guys as you're watching you hear
something that really resonates with you
please leave it in comments below put
quotes around it so other people could
be inspired as well enjoy a first at
number one is you become what you
believe with Oprah Winfrey create the
highest grandest vision possible for
your life because you become what you
believe when I was a little girl
Mississippi growing up on the farm only
Bukka weed is a role model watching my
grandmother boil clothes and a big iron
pot through the screen door because we
didn't have a washing machine and made
everything we had I watched her and
realized somehow inside myself and the
spirit of myself that although this was
segregated Mississippi and I was colored
and female that my life could be bigger
greater than what I saw I remember being
4 or 5 years old I certainly couldn't
articulate it but it was a feeling and a
feeling that I allowed myself to follow
I loud myself to follow because if you
were to ask me what is the secret to my
success it is because I understand that
there is a power greater
than myself that rules my life and in
life in life if you can be still long
enough in all of your endeavors the good
times the hard times to connect yourself
to the source I call it God you can call
it whatever you want to the force nature
Allah the power if you can connect
yourself to the source and allow the
energy that it is your personality your
lifeforce to be connected to the greater
force in the thing is possible for you I
am proof of that I think that my life
the fact that I was born where I was
born
and the time that I was and have been
able to do what I've done
speaks to the possibility not that I am
special but that it could be done number
two is just start with Mark Zuckerberg
ideas don't come out fully formed they
only become clear as you work on them
you just have to get started if I had to
know everything about connecting people
before I got started I never would have
built Facebook movies and pop culture
just get this all wrong the idea of a
single Eureka moment is a dangerous lie
it makes us feel inadequate because we
feel like we haven't had ours yet and it
prevents people with seeds of good ideas
from ever getting started in the first
place
number three is create the best products
with Bill Gates well certainly every
product we do is absolutely as capable
as it can possibly be you know there's
nothing there's no holding back we are
the people at Microsoft come into work
every day building the best products
they can and they're very proud you need
to go out go into schools and see how
kids are using this stuff going ask
people about how their jobs have changed
because of the personal computer you
know we're sitting there listening to
our customers saying how they'd like to
make things better so we're we do
absolutely our best job and in fact
that's why we've been successful you
know anybody who holds back and
this business isn't gonna be around for
long because this is a business where
you always have to be moving at a very
rapid pace number four
execute your idea with Jeff Bezos it's
easy to have ideas it's very hard to
turn an idea into a successful product
there are a lot of steps in between it
takes persistence relentlessness so I
always tell people who are you know who
think they want to be entrepreneurs it's
you need a combination of stubborn
relentlessness and flexibility and you
have to know when to bewitch and
basically you need to be stubborn on
your vision because otherwise it'll be
too easy to give up but you need to be
very flexible on the details because as
you go along pursuing your vision you'll
find that some of your preconceptions
were wrong you're gonna need to be able
to change those things so I think taking
an idea successfully all the way to the
market and turning it into a real
product that people care about and that
really improves people's lives it's a
lot of hard work number five works smart
with Jack Ma who works harder the people
at eBay are the people of Alibaba it's
sometimes you have not only have to work
how you have to work smart mm-hmm so
would you say you work smarter than I
pay I'd have to say yes right well it's
so far yeah so so far okay because
because I think you know we are pretty
lucky people and the people see you yeah
you work very hard chew in this or that
so many people work very hard but
they're not that I told my team when we
I'd pill I asked a lot of people sitting
there I say you know what of you guys
motovlog I millionaires and so rich but
15 years ago who are we it's so
difficult for us to hide people fifteen
years ago people who are not that bad
I said people can walk still walk on
stream we hire them because nobody
believed internet nobody believed
internet and they join a company though
people who believe they're smart they
were had hunted back to the other
company they set up their own company
those people no nobody go to hell
Huntingdon this state today the big
successful very rupee reasons we exist
would persist we never give up we
believe the dreams together number six
don't chase money with Larry Ellison our
goal was to get we started with four
employees and our goal was to get to 50
employees and the goal really was not so
much to make a lot of money I mean I'm
on it I wanted to me a lot of money in
those days was I want to own a house I
want to have a nice car and I wanted to
work with interesting people and do
interesting things and I thought if I
could control my own environment have a
small consulting company and oracle
started out as a software consulting
company we work for tandem computer if
anyone remembers those guys we work for
IBM that we work for a lot of different
tech companies in Silicon Valley doing
contract programming fixed-price
contract programming and we did pretty
well actually and and again the idea was
just to have a small software contract
software company budget you know we
thought were a hotshot programmers and
we thought it could make a decent living
doing just that and quite by accident we
built a product number seven get out of
your comfort zone with Richard Branson
so it looks like you always go out of
your comfort zone right coming onto an
island that was completely deserted no
fresh water you don't even have the
money to buy it and and now you're
sleeping on a tent on the beach trying
to figure out how to get fresh water
here you do that often you did it with
the airline I mean I was just somebody
that experienced the bad experience of
traveling on airlines I was actually
trying to get to the BVI the British
Virgin Islands one day from Puerto Rico
and the same lovely lady was waiting for
me and I've been away for three weeks
and American Airlines bumped the flight
and and so I went to the back of the
airport I had a plane I had a black
board I wrote Virgin Airlines one-way
$29 to the VV I went around all the
people have been bumped and I filmed my
first plane and that got me thinking you
know their lines do bump people they
don't care about you or me we take
in the air and so we say then rang up
Boeing and said you have any second
seven four seven okay I mean it was
literally that you just sat in the
airport and said I'm starting an airline
right now because I'm frustrated exactly
and I think most most of the best
entrepreneurial ideas come out of
frustration I think you know if you if
you're frustrated about something and
the best way of sorting it out is get
out and do it and you've got yourself a
business number eight have a good work
ethic with Alan Michael sugar when you
come from the working-class background
that I come from I feel guilty at ten to
five if I'm not in the office I know
that might sound strange to you but
that's a work ethic that I have to be
half-dead not to not go to work it's a
kind of a work ethic that's built into
me yeah but nevertheless having said all
that the weekends that was it it's over
switch off like a like Friday night as
you got back from the office or from the
work or from the factory or whatever if
they would matter what was buzzing
around in my head it was off like a
light switch and that's it don't let it
interfere very rarely let it interfere
with the weekend and then Monday morning
bang back on it again as if you flick
the switch on again so I think that was
a bit of discipline in that respect
number nine is be consistent with a
little tango thing even must be
consistent when you try a business and
you start you might have hiccups here
and there but it doesn't mean that that
business is not going to work there must
be challenges in fact what I keep saying
that life without challenges is very
very boring so if you have challenges
you just have to know how to work out
how to work around these challenges and
it will be successful once you are
consistent what business does it like is
for you to try something and then once
you have one or two problems and I want
to change and move into another business
that doesn't work
business satchel and number 10 is solve
bigger problems with Larry Page and I
think become and for all of you there
are many areas where there's leverage
available in the world where you know
one or two people a good idea a lot of
hard work can really make a difference
there's many many things like that and
it's good not to forget that but it's
good to look for those things googles
mission is to organize the world's
information and make it universally
accessible and useful and one of the
things that surprised me that's a very
broad mission it's a lot of work we're
not going to achieve it anytime soon
right it's almost an impossible task but
it's an exciting task and one that you
can get other people excited about and
they can help you and one of the things
that all surprised me is sometimes
easier to do something that's harder
because other people get excited about
it and you can get much more resource
you can get tremendous resources to
solve a hard problem whereas you might
only get minor resources to solve a
small problem thank you guys so much for
watching I hope you enjoyed I'd love to
know which rule had the biggest impact
on you what did you learn from this
video that you will immediately apply to
your thinking to your life to your
business please leave become and let me
know that below I'm really excited to
see what you have to say and as always
guys I believe in you I hope you
continue to believe in yourself and
whatever your one where it is much love
[Music]
the most important word ever if you had
to think of one word that's most
important to you or that sums you Apple
that would be like a little beacon pay
believe nation if you want to know what
the most important one word is for Tony
Robbins Gary Vaynerchuk Oprah Winfrey
will.i.am and Howard Schultz I have a
very special secret video for you check
the description for details
[Music]
you